everyone love a UV light on fire say
yeah about the blackout tarp is pretty
good because there - hey what's up guys
we got Danny and John here from vat19
and they've brought a very special gift
for us all to try today and I'm
terrified to say the least
you can't make it any hotter maybe
chilli extract and that's an oil we had
the guy make this for us and but you had
this special yeah we got it made for us
he came with the first batch and I was
like I can put a little bit more any but
if I put too much in it it'll melt like
we'll call it the world's hottest and
put it with the most in so this is the
most chilli extract you can get a
chocolate before it just turns into
liquid Wow you get a little bit of an
addiction to it like you get a little
bit of it I got an adrenaline yeah no
you will feel like kind of like am not
imagining drama bass is going into your
stomach I wanted to hit this it's my
stomach lining so I'm gonna eat some
food quick smaller than I expected so
the challenge is the 12 squares one
square every minute or however long you
can do it how many squares if you can do
I just never show them for each other
just off your mouth
oh he's chewing - mm-hmm you feeling it
already don't worry about don't worry
about it
train I turned every night oh man even
if we sit at the same time it's like
Last Man Standing
touch your eyes oh wow that's an
immediate burn it's like it's like a
thousand microscopic daggers stabbing
chuckling yeah look it up yeah it's
bunch of nanobots are trying to
interface with my taste buds if you go
for number two your fingertips might
start to tingle which is really fun
also here's the thing you whoever drinks
milk first this is uh I'm getting
hiccups much better man yet we're
shooting the video what does it call
Clint called the Pete
say it properly this is about some guy
who accidentally takes a picture of his
junk he goes through everything he can
do this man does everything he can do to
stop his junk from being uploaded on
Instagram that's the video today we are
using Clint's car and we need to
simulate it like as if it's moving at
high speeds but we're not gonna be
actually driving it we're gonna use the
long lens try to get some kind of blown
out background so you can't really tell
what's behind him so it's obscured and
then we're gonna use a bounce car to
simulate light flashes passing his face
and I think after everything said and
done the little can of shake it's gonna
look real it's hot
in this video the hero is trying to undo
an accident in the digital world so he
opens up our breaker box and rips out
the wires I'm not just taking all this
because these have lots of why he like
pulls away pulls out a whole lot we're
just using all the wire we have in the
studio I'm just shoving it in there for
a comedic effect just in time
you guys are witnessing taking pictures
of everyone with the new merchandise for
the new corridor digital store that's
right it's finally back by popular
demand Sam and I have spent all year
vetting a new manufacturer going out to
designers that we already know and
getting new designs from them getting a
new storefront built all for this
because we wanted to do something that
was cooler that was bigger
that was better quality something that
would be in place for a long time moving
forward we finally found that the
quarter digital store is going to be
open this Thursday August 30th our first
run is five items it's four items plus a
limited edition anime TV that we had
designed around the anime self-driving
cars video it's gonna be available from
the 30th for 10 days and 10 days only so
if you guys don't buy it in that time
just like this hat that so many of you
have asked about it won't ever be for
sale again but the rest of the items
will be in store and they are so sweet
we've got this Stone wash tea with this
really stop Stone wash fabric with this
cool texture on it in the corridor logo
you guys have been asking
for dad hats against what we've got a
dad sweatshirt look at that sweatshirt
that Clint has on and we've got this
white Noiz long-sleeve just in time for
fall and of course the limited edition
anime shirt which is also long-sleeve
just in time for fall I'm super excited
about this because it's been eight
months in the making and now it's
finally here so this Thursday August
30th go and check it out this is real oh
man it's so spicy I can't think of any
more analogy it's just like you're
walking through hell this is just you
get the participation trophy I suppose
but you're out here any drink milk
the problem though we said he did three
but will drink the milk meaning it is a
sign of weakness
I'm gonna run really fast with my mouth
open I win today but I will lose
tomorrow it's like I'm like doing this
but tomorrow morning these tears are
gonna be sad I'm not gonna do another
one I might just go take a nap reverse
with it you know I ever done okay all
right before I went to a hot sauce shop
they gave me some hot sauce and I
started thinking in water from the water
phone there is no no healing glad you
don't want to drink the water because
because it's an oil capsaicin capsaicin
it's an oil so when you add water into a
drink water all it does is literally
just lifts up the oil and spread it
evenly across the larger area instead of
serving milk at the hot sauce shop they
actually serve you like pieces of bread
or tortilla chips because I would have
absorbs the oil good a tuple big bag of
Doritos when I start breathing it in I
felt it like getting into my lungs a
little bit in my nose I example ate them
all
yeah the petrol man that's a good idea
it's a good idea
pepto makes you sick on the third one I
accidentally inhaled too fast in the
thing weight onto my little gullet my
uvula is on fire right now
on fire say yeah yeah so we got this
fake circuit breaker that I'm gonna be
ripping out we're gonna use the little
light rigs to backlight at this and then
we'll add Sparks and post Nico concocted
a little black-powder bomb and he's
thrown in there
should we did a test outside yeah it's
not bad shanks done Sakura was still
safety first so this plus these may
close my eyes and flipping away from it
it's gonna be a three to one they're
gonna watch the clinton he's kind of
yanking away right there as the spaces
turned away he's starting to fall and
the wires coming out I'm gonna hit the
popper I may see the same tiny d3
flickers like okay call roll camera call
action about three two one and then of
course to do our thing click you'll
probably get a little bit of like dust
popping in your face so that's we're
gonna spritz you down it won't do
anything more than sting at the worst
Brendan and I made this box 15 years ago
it's our little pyro switch board it's
very basic but it gets the job done
are you ready yeah I mean we could do
another one if you want like so do you
perfect pepper tech yeah that was the
perfect size the perfect amount sparks
let's do one more we can we get one more
I'll build another one
[Applause]
oh yeah I felt the sparks dude that was
so good man wow it works so much
sparks getting so good yeah so we did
this vat19 collab where they came by and
they let me have one of these pieces of
chocolates like hey if you want any if
you guys want to try the challenge go
for it so here it is but it's not that
I'll do one it's like a Hershey kiss
here son I'm not gonna touch the stuff
that is goodbye
I mean right now it's not that I mean
it's hot I mean it's hot it's more of a
mental hot though you know if you like
think about it it's not there dude can
you beat Sam can you do five T's okay
that's pretty high I mean if I don't
like I said if I don't think about the
heat it's not there I mean it's there
until the story about gravity takes to
one time charm is pretty good because
there
yeah I'm feeling that one though no Joe
that's the one I'm feeling done never
again a seven no I did one for Brett
never him now that we are big boys we
make big boy videos and since we're also
big boys we have big boy and merch this
isn't your average logo on a t-shirt
kind of stuff this is logo on a stylish
t-shirt kind of stuff we are working
with some guys who are some really
really great clothing designers that got
their pulse there we go they got a
finger on possible fashion and they're
helping us design clothing that not only
helps rep the channel represents your
love for the videos but also is good
stuff to wear and makes you look like
you live in the year 2018 all right yeah
so if you like the videos take a look at
the shirts and if you know someone who
doesn't like our videos but likes good
clothing maybe recommend it to them as
well
yeah we're not here